[Music]
hey guys mkbhd here with a review of the
beats by dre solo HDS by monster cable
you've probably already noted that I
didn't do an unboxing of these
headphones and that's because you
probably know what to expect in a
headphone package well you're gonna get
with the solo HDS is the audio cable
itself separate from the headphones and
all packaged in this nice little mesh
case and as we all know it's always
great to see a headphone manufacturer
that includes some extras with their
headphones so after that introduction
what I can actually go ahead and do now
is show you what's in the package and
how I've packaged them alright now we
have the beats by dre solo HDS that are
on the main compartment of the pouch and
you actually have your control talk cuz
what they call the control talk
headphones that are a nice red and black
design in the pouch that is also within
the mesh case I think these headphones
didn't come with the mesh case that it
does come packaged with it would
probably be a whole different deal and I
even be a deal breaker I don't want to
go too in depth on the package but you
can see it's a nice red and black design
and on the inside it has this pouch on
the left-hand side that allows you to
keep your headphones and your cables in
the same pouch so that's a nice little
convenient accessory that they've
included and thrown in when you're
buying such a nice pair of headphones I
can't do a solo H to use headphone
review without talking about the monster
cables themselves as you guys probably
know monster cable is best known for
their cable products HDMI etc and these
are no exception the beats by dre come
with these gold-tipped right angle and
straight a cable that actually comes
separate from the headphones so you plug
the right angle cable into your mp3
player and E because you can see there's
four rings there one for the microphone
and on the left hand side you can
actually plug in a straight angle cable
and that goes directly into the beats
headphones so if you happen to damage
either the headphones or the cable you
can only replace one of them and you
won't have to go out and buy a whole new
separate pair of headphones you also
notice this pretty nice control talk
feature which actually has a microphone
a volume up button a volume down button
and a play/pause button and those will
work with I devices on this side that
plugs into your actual beats by dre
headphones
and now let's get into the headphones
themselves well first of all they're
extremely portable as you can tell by
number one the case it comes in a number
two in the nice foldable design it's
made of a durable plastic so you can
still move it around but once you unfold
it and put it on your ears it feels just
about as sturdy as ever also one thing
to note is the customized
customizability of these headphones you
can adjust their width their height you
can adjust how wide it is
it's really quite durable so you can
change it to whatever your head size or
shape is and it's not going to be a
problem one thing to note that I really
like about these headphones is how
comfortable they are I actually wore
these headphones for a six hour car ride
from Pittsburgh to my actual home and it
actually wasn't that difficult to wear
for six straight hours now I did take
them off occasionally to listen to some
other things like the car radio but I'm
telling you right now these headphones
won't be a problem for up to four or
five hours of listening if you're doing
some editing or something like that with
these headphones on now I can already
see the comments about how these
headphones aren't the most durable or
how someone they know actually got a
chance to break their solos or solo HDS
and I'm telling you now those people
were doing something very wrong with
their headphones as you can see about
what I'm doing in this video they're
really durable and will stand up to
everyday use typical music listening
head-banging for pretty much a let or
lifetime these are really really durable
headphones if you really throw them
around or don't use a pouch and then
just put them in a backpack or something
they might have a better chance of
breaking but if you gette take good care
of your headphones you won't have a
problem with the solo HDS now pardon the
appearance of a Zune HD in a video where
the control talk on these headphones
doesn't actually work for anything other
than I devices but I obviously don't
have an apple piece of hardware to
demonstrate this with so I can show you
my best with a Zune HD the right angle
clip cable goes into the zoom or your
mp3 player this could even be your cell
phone and the straight angle actually
goes into the headphones and band just
like that you're connected and ready to
listen to some music you can use the
control talk end of the cable to talk to
people on the phone as there is a
built-in microphone and you can also
control playing and pausing of music and
volume increase and decrease on your
iPod iPhone or iPad overall I have to
say this is an extremely nice pair of
headphones and by far the best I've ever
used and these are going
come my permanent editing headphones
from here on into the future and I
definitely want to thank monster cable
for sending these out to review I'm
going to give these headphones and nine
and a half out of ten for one or two
reasons actually one because the control
talk feature doesn't actually work for
the Zune HD or the Droid that I'm using
and second of all because these
headphones after the sixth hour car ride
that I went on started to get
uncomfortable so if these headphones
were somehow ridiculously durable and
didn't have any comfortable issues and
actually the control talk worked with
all the mp3 players in the world these
headphones would be a 10 out of 10 in
other words if you've got durable ears
and an iPod and go for these headphones
so I hope I've told you all you need to
know and until next time mkbhd signing
out peace